imagine this your aircraft has
state-of-the-art
avionics but your map is from the 15th
century
commanded by please advise
neuroscientists are stuck in this
harrowing predicament as they try to
make their way around the human brain
the first classical map made about a
century ago it is still widely used
today published in 1909 it defined
regions on the pinkish gray organ that
control our actions and functions the
fundamental unit of brain organization
for the cerebral cortex is what we call
a cortical area so on the map you could
say there's a country called speech and
under called short-term memory another
hand movement identifying every one of
these cortical areas became a major
objective of the human connectome
project the HCP meeting the effort a
master map maker I consider myself a
cortical cartographer by July of last
year the HCP completed its first phase a
21st century world map of the brain we
reported the presence of 180 distinct
cortical areas 97 of them were new to
brain science the connectome gives us
this opportunity a really great tool to
be able to navigate the human brain
navigating the brain is more than just
naming cities and states you need to
understand the connections between them
the word connect home implies that the
fundamentally important thing about
brains is connections this evening we'll
be talking and learning about two
different kinds of connections
structural connections in the brain
versus functional connections in the
brain by structural connections we're
really time at the physical connections
of wires that connect nerve cells so
structural connectivity looks at the
regions and the pathway is connecting
them the functional connectivity though
is more about how different parts of the
brain work together on an ongoing basis
brain function arises from conversations
that different brain regions are having
with each other a functional map must
track living data conversations flowing
through the pathways between brain
regions we collected data from 1200
individuals when you have them do
different tasks in the scanner things
like a memory task emotions on faces
those same regions of the brain seem to
be forming networks brain structure
is wired by its experience but we have
no idea in what form that wiring diagram
has that information and that's the big
puzzle to see how that translates into
individual nerve connections you need to
look much closer than David or Deanna's
technology can go down to the level of
individual neurons to quadrillion times
smaller
what exactly is 2 quadrillion times
smaller well
Jeff's covering would be a city about
the size of say Sheboygan Wisconsin that
little blur that little blob there might
be Sheboygan are not sure that little
blob is a 1 millimeter cube of brain
tissue and it contains a staggering
number of neurons 50,000 nerve cells and
about 1 billion synapses so right now
there's no way to model an entire human
brain by diagramming its micro wiring
scientifically for now were lost in the
foggy limits of brain science it would
need more digital information than is
the actual digital content of the world
[Music]